athens greece
2004 olympic games
american rifle shooter matthew emmons is
leading by three points
one more shot to secure a gold medal in
the 50-meter three-rifle target event
a score of 7.2 is all that's needed
his lowest score over the previous 9
shots was 9.3
he takes aim
shoots and hits for what would be an 8.1
point shot if it was his target
evans in lane two aimed at the lane
three target
it's called a crossfire and it cost him
gold dropping him all the way down to
eighth
edmonds admitted that he was more
concerned with calming himself down than
looking at his target
he wasn't focused on the right thing
at the right time
jill is a 16 year old talented club
soccer player that i'm working with
she's developed performance anxiety
despite her skills
she plays tentatively at times doesn't
take shots on goal
she's not responding to traditional
psychological skills training like
relaxation
she's locked onto her fear of making a
mistake
as we explore this fear she reveals to
me a young sport memory
about five years earlier she definitely
stole the ball from an opponent spotted
an opening at the net and quickly scored
a goal
for the other team she'd gotten turned
around and in her excitement lost focus
on her field position and wanted to make
a play
fortunately the coach was supportive and
understanding but jill said she was
mortified
she wasn't focused on the right thing
at the right time
in rio
2016 summer olympics british virgin
island runner ashley kelly admitted that
she had gotten distracted during her 23
second 200 meter race
she said i felt i had a very good start
but i wasn't sure what to do when
veronica campbell brown stayed in my
lane after drifting across the bend i'm
not blaming her because i lost my focus
and i should have come back to thinking
about my performance
kelly finished fifth
less than a second off a time that would
have qualified her for the semi-finals
instead
her olympic run was over
is there a more important psychological
skill for performers than focused
attention
as these stories illustrate i don't
think so
jill for example performed with
intensity confidence and great physical
skills executing the play and beating
the goalie but it was her goalie
a great performance wasted
and in some sports like diving
gymnastics and figure skating
a loss of focus can be devastating to
performance risking injury or
contributing to the loss of skills
in fact the biggest problem i see when
gymnasts and figure skaters come to me
is that they've lost a skill that they
used to perform with relative ease
in just about all their cases their
attention has shifted usually from what
they're doing to what they're thinking
or feeling
macky sasser is an extreme example
the catcher for the new york mets became
unable to throw the ball back to the
pitcher
a critical problem that ended his career
maggie explained how it started with a
change in throwing motion due to injury
but then as his body healed his throwing
mechanics didn't
his focus was off attending to
everything from the fans to his own
bodily sensations of fear it wasn't
until after he had to retire and
treatment for the childhood traumas that
were unconsciously related and
interfering with his focus did his
ability return
so you see without focus some
performances can become impossible
so let's start with a definition
when we talk about attention we could
mean one of six things
there's biological arousal or alertness
a state of readiness to respond to the
environment
my rapid heart rate and muscle tension
before a race for example
there's the orienting response which is
quite automatic where attention is
reflectively directed to an unexpected
stimulus a fan blows an air horn during
a free throw disrupt a basketball
player's attention for instance
there's the visual search where we shift
our attention toward a specific region
of visual space
think of a quarterback checking off his
receivers from one side of the field to
the next
and selective attention which is the
ability to tune into a specific source
of information while ignoring other
information
mental resources or the mental effort
that fuels cognitive activity
the ability to think
and finally when we talk about attention
we could be talking about the overall
supervisory process that regulates our
intentional attention
researchers have boiled it down further
to three aspects or dimensions of
attention
concentration refers to a person's
intentional decision to invest mental
effort on what's most important at the
time
an american football player for example
will listen intently to the quarterback
as a play is called in the huddle
the second dimension is selective
attention or the ability to zoom in on
task relevant information while ignoring
distractions
as a wide receiver being able to focus
on the ball and catch it in your hands
and not tune into the defender coming at
you requires selective attention
selective attention is challenged by
sudden onset stimuli and movement
to use a non-sport example it's why the
cursor on your computer monitor blinks
stands out from the static text
third and finally there's divided
attention
performers often have to do more than
one thing at a time
keeping with the football example a
quarterback must be aware of the
oncoming rush of defenders the receivers
and the defensive backs covering them
then there are his own mechanics like
footwork
a young football player will have a
tremendous difficulty doing all of this
a novice may not be able to focus on
much more than footwork and one receiver
but with extensive practice a player can
learn to perform two three or more
concurrent actions equally well
one of the more popular ways to explain
attention is the spotlight metaphor
and is particularly useful in
performance
this metaphor conceptualizes attention
as a mental beam to finding a limited
part of the visual field and as the
information outside that field is
getting ignored
this metaphorical beam can be redirected
voluntarily so as a sports psychologist
using this metaphor i can help an
athlete see that concentration is never
truly lost just directed at the wrong
target
it reminds performers that they have
control over where they shine their
attention
yes it can be a challenge
you may be so nervous and focus on your
rapid heart rate quite automatically
but how quickly you recognize this and
how you respond to it is under your
control
do you let that beam continue to
illuminate your anxiety
or do you redirect it back to the
present moment and the play that needs
to be made
it's your choice
performers direct their attention across
two dimensions
broad to narrow
meaning the performer is examining a
large number of cues broad
to a limited number or ultimately one
narrow
the second dimension considers attention
outside the body or external
to internal or inside the body
with a narrow internal focus the
performer is concentrating on a specific
internal sensation or mental process
like imagery
this can be helpful for a marathon
runner tuning into specific sensations
like their breathing or a golfer
imagining the perfect putt
a broad external focus is needed when an
athlete has to assess a situation
quickly see what options are available
before deciding on the best course of
action
think of an american football running
back taking the handoff and needing to
look for the hole to run through as five
linemen try to block six defensive
players
external focus outside of himself and
broad focus seeing the field and
blocking in front of him is critical
the more internal his attention becomes
the less he can process what's going on
in the game as it's happening
and the narrower his vision becomes it
increases the chances he may fail to see
that the hole closed up and bouncing it
outside may be a better option
a broad external focus can seem
distracted if attention is needed in one
of the three other quadrants
tuning into too many things or
unnecessary details
eyes may dart to what the coach is doing
on the sideline or or hearing the boos
from the fans
in the examples i started with the
british virgin island runner seemed to
briefly switch to a broad external focus
to assess the threat of the other runner
in her lane
if she risked collision this would have
been useful but that wasn't the case and
briefly moving from her narrow external
focus on a powerful stride interfered
with a peak performance
in this third quadrant narrow external
it's important to minimize those
distractions and to focus energy in a
specific direction to execute skills and
maximize effort often in relation to
something in the playing field like a
baseball player swinging at a pitch
when athletes are performing their best
they tend to stay external and flow
across the broad to narrow continuum as
needed
problems arise when they get distracted
by internal experiences
for example a mistake is made and they
get stuck in their thoughts or feelings
focusing on the internal when an
external attentional focus is needed is
what causes choking
a golfer needing to execute a short but
important putt can get distracted by her
nerves and worry interrupt the flow of
her putt and miss the shot
but a broad internal focus is best when
the performer needs to analyze and plan
past information is recalled and
compared to present conditions to pick
the best course of action
so this spotlight can shine in one of
these four quadrants
and while this metaphor is practically
useful sports scientists have three
criticisms first
how do we identify what process governs
the spotlight
second emotional influences are ignored
in this model
practically speaking i find this the
greatest limitation in my work with
athletes emotional reactions tend to be
the most distracting
the third criticism is that this
metaphor ignores what's happening
outside of the spotlight and the effects
of unconscious factors on our attention
i'm sure that kelly did not choose to
focus on the runner in her lane but
rather it happened quite automatically
it made her lose focus as we so commonly
call it
but what does that mean do we truly lose
focus
the spotlight metaphor suggests that we
choose incorrectly when we have a choice
but unconscious and emotional factors
suggest that we don't always have a
choice at least not initially
to do your best a performer needs two
things in their concentration
the correct specific target and focusing
only on the actions that are under their
control
this doesn't mean for example that
factors such as field conditions or wins
should be ignored absolutely not
but they should be considered only at
the right time and place when planning
is appropriate
once it comes time to perform and you
decide on an action that you want to
commit to taking all those factors
already into account
then the ideal focus is when you're
performing on a specific controllable
target
but distractions happen
athletes who casually say oh i just lost
focus i'll do better next time they put
themselves at a disadvantage
you didn't forget to focus
you haven't developed the skill
and you can improve it
so hold yourself accountable
you may never be perfect sometimes the
best we can do is catch it early as
humanly possible and refocus back onto
the appropriate target
one that's important to the task at hand
under our control and in the present
moment
we spoke about matthew emmons to open up
this lecture
after the crossfire emmons explained he
usually looks at the number of the
target through his viewfinder as a
reference point and then he lowers his
gun to hone in on the target
but
quote
on that shot i was just worrying about
calming myself down and just breaking a
good shot so i didn't even look at the
number
i probably should have i will from now
on
he got distracted by something that was
irrelevant to the shot and out of his
control his anxiety
he abandoned what was under his control
executing his pre-shot routine
so do we control our attention or don't
we
i think it's fair to say that we do a
little bit of both
we greatly influence it
we can get very good about where we
direct it but ultimately it's not a
hundred percent under our control
remember one of the criticisms of the
spotlight metaphor was who controls the
spotlight
well researchers have suggested a dual
process of cognitive functioning
wegner's ironic process theory helps
explain why attentional lapses happen at
the worst times
attention wanders because we try to
control it hence the irony
take a musician who doesn't want to make
a mistake on a difficult piece of music
he doesn't want to think about the
potential mistake or the worry or the
physical sensations that he may be
feeling
he wants to focus on playing each note
in the moment
so there's a conscious controlled search
for the ideal focused thoughts
but at the same time
there's a simultaneous second process
going on that's automatic and
unconscious that searches for any sign
of the unwanted thought to be sure the
mind is being successful
checking in to be sure it isn't there
makes it be there
the thoughts we try to suppress come to
mind more easily than the thought we
want to focus on and this is a
phenomenon called hyper accessibility
and it's especially likely to occur
under conditions of mental load because
conscious intentional focusing takes a
lot of mental energy this is real energy
and when we're tired or the pressure's
too great and we're anxious
we don't have as much strength to
control our thoughts
our mind is text
and then it wanders to wherever
fortunately we have five principles of
effective concentration to teach
so that skilled performance is maximized
the first is simple but it's critical
you've got to decide to concentrate it
absolutely will not just happen by
chance or automatically be there when
you need it
because it takes energy it can be
helpful to turn it on and off with a
performance routine
baseball batters will step out of the
box for example after a pitch and let
their mind relax with their body
as they begin to prepare for the next
pitch they make a commitment to focus
and then step back into the box to begin
their routine
they've made the batter's box a place
that demands their full attention
the second principle is to focus only on
one thought at a time
we often try to do too much
research on the bandwidth of our
effective attention is limited to just
one item
when we multi-task we either shift
rapidly between doing things one at a
time or in succession
or one or more of the simultaneous
actions haven't practiced so much that
they become automatic and don't require
conscious control
we don't want to be thinking and talking
to ourselves as we perform
that can slow up or disrupt a
complicated task like a golf swing for
example
there are times especially when learning
a new skill that a single q word can be
helpful to trigger the right feeling or
tempo of the desired action
but too many words may not keep our
attention so something like head rather
than keep my head steady
is preferred
let me give you two of my favorite
focusing exercises that help performers
limit their attention to what is most
important
the first is what's my
job before going into a game an athlete
wants to identify two or three behaviors
that are under their control to
emphasize
yes there are a ton of things to do in
basketball for example dribble well take
the open shot communicate to teammates
give full effort keep hands up on
defense be aware of the talented guard
execute the play and more
but with all the things to do
and coaches coaching and parents
coaching from the sidelines in a
pressure game it can get overwhelming
when an athlete knows what her job is
two or three behaviors specific to focus
on and come back to
it helps ground them in the chaos
they can then play with purpose and
determination
true story
i was working with a high school
basketball player whose coach who they
loved transferred to a rival high school
so this athlete who was talented and
seeing me for performance anxiety was
getting particularly stressed about this
upcoming game
they wanted to beat that old coach so
bad and show her that she shouldn't have
left them
but my athlete was distracted she wanted
to play well wanted to win wanted to
impress her coach and was distracted by
her emotions
so she identified that her job was to
one take the open shot
two keep her hands up on defense and
three communicate on the floor
we check does she know how to do her job
yes she does
she understands how to do this we check
can she do her job
yeah she's physically capable the job is
realistic and within her skills
and finally and this is where athletes
can really struggle
will she do her job now this took a
moment
we had to talk about her commitment to
these behaviors she worried that it
wasn't enough it sounded too simple
that she needed to focus on and do more
she wanted
i explained why she needed a limited
focus to go back to when nervous
i find that many athletes will not
commit at this point
making the technique useless
but she committed to these jobs
so
game time comes and it's a great game
back and forth and she tells me that
she's encouraging her teammates and she
looks across at her coach and gets
nervous she keeps going back to her job
on the court she's hustling keeping her
hands up and it's the end of the game
and they're down by two
and they pass it to her and she's
focused on her job taking the open shot
and swish makes the basket as time
expires to be her coach
oh my gosh she's telling me this story
and i'm like this is a disney movie
she's crying the team's crying i'm
almost crying and she's telling me the
story they go over and they hug their
coach on the other side
she credited what's my job for her
focused success
another one i like is a bit easier to
remember i tell my athletes do you want
to win
well that stands for what's important
now
w i n
what's important now
what's great about this technique is
anytime that you're confused or
overwhelmed or stuck on a mistake or
nervous about the future you just go
wait wait a minute
what's important now
and it brings you right back to the
present moment and some action thought
that will best help you perform
now at any given moment of any
performance there'll be some specific
thing that is most important for you to
be doing or focusing on
occasionally some of my younger players
don't know exactly where their best
focus should be so this creates a
wonderful coaching opportunity because
if you have no idea what you should be
focused on no wonder you're not focused
on the right thing
so when
what's important now
our third principle for good
concentration is to do exactly what
you're thinking or think specifically
about what you want to do
you're truly focused and will have your
best performance when there is no
difference between what you are thinking
and what you are doing
keep your head and your body in the same
place
this comes from the research on flow
states and being in the zone
keep thoughts positively phrased
regarding what you will do
not what you don't want to do
and this principle reminds me of one of
the more powerful focusing tips that i
give my golfers
commit to the club
how many times are you debating between
hitting a short five iron or a long six
and just grab one then on your backswing
with the five you're thinking you wish
you had your six and it doesn't turn out
well
your lack of commitment to the club
ruins your focus and invites all kinds
of doubt
commit to the club
then commit to how you will swing that
club
and then when it's time to execute the
swing you can be totally focused on
executing that specific plan
it'll save you numerous strokes
you're welcome
now the fourth principle is to focus
only on factors under your control
why well because if you can't control it
why invest mental energy into it
we have a limited amount of attention
and if half or three quarters of it is
spent on something that you can't
control you have less attentional energy
to spend on what you can control
what happens when your opponent is using
all of his attentional energy on factors
that control his performance
better performance
but those uncontrolled distractions have
some power don't they they feel
important and sometimes athletes will
argue that they are important and of
course they are
the score matters your opponents matter
the weather and field conditions matter
but you can't control them and they
matter
but the time to consider them is usually
before the game or during breaks in the
action to plan to choose equipment and
strategize
and all that should be done so that when
you're actually performing those factors
out of your control have already been
addressed
allowing you to focus on what you can
and do control
i like to think of it as circles and you
want to hit the target circle in the
center the circle of control
we don't control what we think and feel
but we do control our reactions to
thoughts and feelings and we control
what we do
and that's where we want to direct our
attention
it can be helpful to list or identify
what things we're concerned about what
affects winning but if it isn't under
our direct control then it's a
distraction in the moment of performance
this is the circle of concern
when we catch ourselves in this circle
we want to recognize it and get back to
the center
anything outside these two circles is
irrelevant
now the last principle kind of goes back
to that internal external dimension of
attention that we spoke of earlier and
that is when you get nervous
focus outward
we're naturally drawn in out of our
performance and get consumed or
distracted by what we feel
when we get stuck inside our doubt we
worry we criticize we become hyper
vigilant of what we fear
screw up
so get out
back into the game
let me conclude with how to develop your
focus skills now you can use the proper
bench press form to lift 250 pounds but
all that technique is not going to help
you if you don't have the strength to
use that technique right
so for these techniques to work best you
need the mental strength to be able to
do them
my number one recommendation is
mindfulness training
the purpose of training is to adopt a
non-judgmental relationship to
distractions while immersing yourself in
the chosen target of attention
this acceptance but detachment from
distractions avoids suppression and the
hyper-accessibility trap
and it's closely related to that flow
state with its grounding in the present
moment
study after study has shown various
mindfulness and mindfulness-based
programs increase flow and performance
as part of this attentional training
another way to build focus is simulation
training or practicing under conditions
that replicate key aspects of an
upcoming challenge
this means getting used to keeping the
distraction in the background
you might hear this most with teams
blaring crowd noise into the practice
stadium to stimulate a hostile awake
crowd
athletes learned a deal
bob bowman swim coach broke michael
phelps goggles so phelps would learn to
swim calmly without them if necessary in
competition
this actually happened in the 2008
olympics when his goggles filled with
water during the last 100 meters of the
200 meter butterfly event
where he won gold
and set a world record
he wasn't distracted
but my favorite example is some
simulation training i did with the
gymnastics team
one athlete when practicing her floor
routine i would mess with her program
music start and stopping it changing the
volume and she had to focus on her
routine and execute skills regardless of
the sound errors
well in a meet soon after her music was
fine but on one particular move when she
whipped her head around snot came out
from her nose and landed on her cheek
and she can't wipe it off but she was
able to let even that distraction go and
nail all her skills
she said she remembered our practice and
to focus on what she was doing
simulation training can help prevent
choking
as i said earlier anxiety causes us to
focus inward
in one study researchers found that
performers who trained in mild anxiety
conditions did equally well in low
mild and high anxiety conditions
but the control group
who practiced without anxiety
their performance deteriorated under
high anxiety conditions
similarly
pre-event and pre-performance routines
can help focus attention these are
specific and structured actions a
performer takes before a performance to
prepare mentally physically and
emotionally
routines usually have a focus component
to guide attention to task relevant cues
and get into the moment
another technique is to use trigger
words as cues to concentrate
skilled performers very often talk to
themselves for motivational and
instructional purposes
british olympic athlete and 2007 new
york city marathon winner paula
radcliffe counted her steps silently to
maintain concentration in the present
moment
she said that when she counted to 100
three times it was a mile
during wimbledon in both 2002 and 2007
serena williams was observed between
games to consult notes that she had
written for herself
short phrases like hit in front and add
spin gave her focused instruction
and finally all performers have outcome
goals
but these desired outcomes can become a
distraction
so setting performance goals
process goals that lie within your
control telling you what to do improves
performance by directing your attention
to the how of performance
for example entering a tennis match with
goals to increase accuracy of first
serves rather than to win directs
attention to actions that directly
improve the chances of winning
we cover a lot of skills in this course
but i don't know if any are more
important than this one
if your attention isn't on what you're
doing
none of the other skills matter focus
can be developed and it's to our
greatest advantage to develop it
[Music]
you